[Music]
everyone is talking about tesla whenever
there is a mention of electric vehicles
but there is yet another eevee
manufacturer that is slowly taking
steady control of the mines of evie
devotees
and this has left us wondering is there
a chance tesla may soon be left out in
the market
could you please take about 30 seconds
of your time to subscribe to our youtube
channel
don't forget to click on the bell button
to stay in touch with all our exciting
updates
gone are the days when we have to wait
for so long at the charging stations to
use our electric vehicles
the chinese electric vehicle startup neo
is presenting a groundbreaking idea of
battery swap systems
challenging tesla and so many other
rival car makers
you want to know how they are doing this
here's how neo and tesla are competing
against each other
for the world's largest ev market in
china and how neo is
probably beating tesla hands down no
doubt
neo was previously on the edge of
bankruptcy however to the surprise of
many
the chinese electric vehicle
manufacturer is currently on track of
becoming one of the biggest ev companies
not only in china but the entire world
currently outplaying
all except tesla it would amaze you to
know how neo got to where they are now
neo started from absolutely nothing but
within a space of just a few years
they are competing with the world's best
in evs
fortunately for the company the very
first launch of their
run electric supercar also became their
turning point in the eevee world
this ep9 not only launched next step
into the market
but gave them the name for which they
are known right now neo
the supercar goes over a range of 260
miles and was built together with the
company's formula e division
with a horsepower of over 1 360
the neo hypercars sold to investors for
over a month dropping
3 million only 6 of the ep9 model was
sold to the investors
while the other 10 were released to the
public for sales
neo's price may however be a setback for
their business since
tesla in all its glory is yet to launch
a car that is that expensive
in 2019 reports revealed that the
company was fighting to hold on
as they were on the brink of bankruptcy
nia was almost going neck deep into the
financial issues that had it so strong
thankfully the chinese government in
early 2020 decided it was time to give
them a strong pull and revive their
business
amazingly the new business situation
with the government not only saved neo
but also placed them to the fifth
position of the most
valuable automaker in the world some
years later neo's position on the table
was right after tesla
toyota volkswagen and byd another
chinese car manufacturing firm
neo has since been working non-stop to
move higher on the list
and apparently their hard work is
recently paying off as they are
seriously working on knocking
tesla down the list you would recall
that tesla has just recently earned
itself a top position on the list of the
leading eevee manufacturers in china
with many tesla products getting sold
more than any other electric vehicle
they have also gone as far as building
their shanghai gigafactory that is sure
to help tesla
keep up with the demands for their
product tesla's success is
interconnected to its accessible
supercharger network
of which there are over 300 sites
scattered across the chinese mainland
as an eevee owner you sure would
appreciate tesla's magnificent concept
of making charging sites available in
every part of the country
personally i believe these accessible
charging sites are part of the
motivation that gets more people into
tesla products
since neo needs to study tesla carefully
if they want to top the chart
they made a move that revealed their
recognition of the importance of fast
charging abilities
however neo has attached their success
to something very different from tesla's
innovation
this concept neo explains as vehicle
battery separation
neo's concept is to make their clients
see the battery as a separate unit from
the car
the concept is in fact very simple as a
driver instead of looking for a charging
site for your car battery
you simply go into one of neo's stores
and get your battery detached for a new
one
now isn't this concept amazing you don't
have to stay still in a particular spot
waiting for long hours to have your
battery charged you simply swap your
battery for a fresh one
with neo's concept a driver can be back
on the road in just a couple of minutes
well this concept is not all that new
and foreign since tesla in 2013
carried out experiments with this sort
of technology in the california-based
trial center
unfortunately the project was abandoned
because superchargers were then
confirmed to be crucially popular and
extremely fast for a good number of
persons
the superchargers were so fast they
reduced ev charging time down from more
than 12 hours plus
with the invention of superchargers
tesla must have decided there is no need
to pursue the battery separation concept
any further
since customers were comfortable with
the model of cars they got
now with neo's breakthrough there are no
doubt clients that prefer an even faster
means of getting the car going
who would want to try out the battery
separation it is on record that neo's
battery separation concept
gets a driver stalled for only 10
minutes and ready to move
the next minute after that funny enough
even with the battery separation concept
used on the ep9 there were no battery
swap stations opened in china for this
service until 2018.
currently though there are over 160
battery swap stations in the entire
country
and now you may be wondering what
process one has to go through to have a
battery swapped at the earliest
the process is simple a booking is first
made on an app which is followed by a
member of staff reversing the car into
the shelter where a piece of
laser-guided machinery
unscrews the existing battery packs and
sends it underground to be charged
while the exhausted battery is
undergoing charging a fully charged
battery from the store is screwed back
into its stead
within 5 to 10 minutes of the driver's
arrival at the site
they are free to drive out once again
you should know that these battery
swapping services don't come for free
and neocar owner is expected to pay
about 150
every month and eighteen hundred dollars
every year this payment allows up to six
battery swaps
at any of the company's swapping sites
there is also a pocket friendly package
offered to secondhand owners
as they are allowed to pay per kilowatt
hour for the energy that would be
required to recharge their flat battery
although this may take a lot of time
this is to encourage those that may not
have the required funds to get a brand
new neo car
it is no secret that battery technology
is still evolving at a very rapid rate
this is the reason most builders of
electric vehicles prefer to fit in
different styles of batteries in so many
models within the same company
just in case something new comes up in
the long run nevertheless
the success of neo's battery swap
stations is thanks to the standardized
battery pack
that can be taken from and also added to
any model
under the company's brand this battery
pack accounts for about ten thousand
seven hundred dollars of the car's
overall cost it can be purchased
together with the car
or rented from the firm neocompany rep
says that about one third of all their
customers
preferred renting the battery packs than
purchasing a new one even with the
wonderful things this battery separation
innovation
is bringing to technology skeptics have
already found a flaw or two
in the swap station's business model
according to them
although the wait time is very short
nonetheless there are only 160 stations
currently in operation
this to the skeptics is a flaw since the
number of stations in operation doesn't
account for clients who live too far
away from the station
or people who may be traveling for
holidays or work purposes
outside the catchment area so what if a
neo's driver's battery gets exhausted in
the middle of nowhere with no single
battery swap station in sight
what next well if you ever find yourself
in this condition
you don't have to worry because neo's
got you covered not only can one charge
neo vehicles like every other ev
but neo also has an app where customers
can request a charging truck
the truck comes fully equipped with
everything needed for a full charge
now how cool is that with the way neo is
moving in their innovation
and the extra special services they
offer their customers there is a strong
possibility they would be trumping tesla
soon
tesla should watch out for this company
in the near future and that's it on neo
versus tesla
a futuristic plan that is expected to
dominate the eevee market
if you loved this video please give us a
like and let us know in the comments
what you think about these car companies
plans for the eevee market
check out our other videos and subscribe
to be a part of simply tech
click on the notification bell to see
our new videos as soon as they're
uploaded